We would like to express the face of the entire rectangle below as a triple.
Here we have a rectangle divided by
these three smaller rectangles.
We see that for each of these three rectangles
the height is 4 units,
and the width is expressed by x,
or at least the first two widths contain x.
The last rectangle has a width of 2.
What is the face of the entire rectangle?
I recommend that you pause the video and think about it.
What is the face of this blue rectangle?
It looks like a square, but let's call it a rectangle,
since all squares are rectangles.
The face is the height in width.
The face here is the height, which is 4,
on the width x2.
And to this we want to add the face of this rectangle,
I guess we can say salmon-colored,
as it is the height 4 on the width 3x.
We can say 4 by 3x,
but how much is 4 by 3x?
Well this is 12x.
We have 3x four times,
so it's 12x.
12x is the face of this salmon-colored rectangle.
Finally, the face of this green rectangle,
we can actually find it right,
because we should not express it through a variable.
Its height is 4 and its width is 2,
so the face will be 4 by 2 or 8.
And we're ready.